is there
a higher percentage of people who are
catholic who study the phenomenon more
than the general population let's say
have you found that
okay so i found that um because i was at
the vatican and i spent time at the
observatory there in castle guindolfo
and um
i know brother guy console mono who is
the observatory he's the jesuit monk
who's the head of the observatory he's
an astronomer
and they have a meteorite collection
there and stuff it's pretty cool so i
got to stay there and i've known him now
for i don't know a lot of a lot of years
i guess
um
i also talked to lots of people at the
vatican um like peter gompel who's a uh
he's he's in his 90s and he is um
he was like a people advisor
and so this is what i can say about
catholicism and
the subject of ufos is that
the people that i've talked to are very
open-minded about it
and just as curious as as you and i are
and some believe and some don't believe
so there's no right at this point
there's no definite kind of dogma or
doctrine
um
about
ufos for the vatican right so um okay so
that said
there when i did get into this this um
research some very odd things happened
to me that
never would have happened to me had i
stayed in
the study of normal catholic history and
stuff like that like so i um i was uh
you know people in my book a lot of them
i i became involved with the invisible
college do you know the people that okay
so i became involved with the invisible
college
and
after about a year and a half i
recognized that every single one of them
either was a practicing catholic or had
been you know had come from a catholic
background
and the ones that were the most intense
into the research we're actually
practicing catholics
and um
i don't understand that actually so i'm
not quite sure why that is the case
but that's the case
do you have any speculation as to why
that may be the case
like ideas you're toying with
i mean it makes it's gonna make it's
gonna sound very crazy and i'm just if i
tell you okay i will tell you what my my
speculation is but there's no proof for
it um it's just what i think
so it has nothing to do with me being a
professor and kind of you know weighing
down okay so basically i think that um
well every single one of them has a
clearance
um most of them were involved in some
way with the
information about ufos and the public
and we know about project blue book and
we know that in with project blue book
there was a disinformation campaign
right and we know some of the people
that were supposed to do that um it
could be that people feel guilty i'm not
sure
and so they go back to the religion of
their youth in order to you know because
it's pretty intense studying ufos
and then maybe just you know make maybe
engaged in disinformation and things
like that i mean this is pretty heavy
and um
i didn't mean to find stuff out like
that you know about
the ufo phenomena i just kind of
happened upon it and
that the work that i do is historical
work mainly so i've done a lot of
history in the campaigns and the stuff
like that
so
yeah so perhaps
that's the reason i'm not quite sure